hey there this is pro flows number 41
I'm Cameron and in this quick tutorial I
want to show you how to give more depth
more life to your photos inside of After
Effects so here you can see I have a
photo called Road JPEG and it's just a
quick key framing of the position where
we're moving from top to bottom and just
given the photo a little bit of motion
but we can make this much much more
interesting without using position
keyframes and let me show you how to do
that so I'm going to turn off the
keyframes here for position go ahead and
close that up I'm gonna go in here I'm
going to create a new solid and I'm
gonna make it a hundred percent white
and we're gonna call this layer one and
I'm gonna go ahead and hit T for
transparency turn down the opacity just
so I can see through here and I'm select
my pen tool and I'm just going to very
quickly create a very rough mask around
my foreground layer here which is my
road here in the foreground
and something like that hit F and I'm
going to feather it
oh maybe somewhere in here hit T for
transparency and turn it back up and
just make sure that I've got my road
pretty much covered here nothing
doesn't have to be perfect cool and I
create another new solid and this one
I'm going to make a little more on the
gray side somewhere right maybe right
here and we will call this layer to hit
T for transparency turn down the
transparency pen tool and I'm going to
select the next layer which is this
there right in here just going a little
bit further back in z space here and
like I said doesn't have to be perfect
and it's going to overlap behind the
white solid so I'll just bring the mast
down here hit f4 feather bring it up to
58 T for transparency bring back the
transparency so I could see it and make
sure my layer is covered here just like
that bring it down behind my white solid
so there we go
I'm going to create another new solid
we'll call this layer three and we're
going to make it a little more gray
maybe right there okay
for transparency to take down the
transparency and this one going to go
somewhere back in here so p4 pen
straw it on here just like this
a feather
like so t for transparency bring up the
transparency make sure it's covered up
as well
[Music]
you know something like so bring it down
to the bottom and maybe adjust it a
little bit more here
okay so let's do one more layer and
we'll go layer new solid and we're going
to make this one black and this will be
called background
bring into the bottom the stacking order
close these all up I'm going to select
one two three and background and I'm
going to right click and say precompose
and we're going to call this
we're going to call this depth
there we go and we can turn that layer
off now back to the road layer we're
going to select that road we're gonna go
to effect we're go to distort
displacement map we're going to change
the displacement map layer to depth and
we're going to change red to luminance
green to luminance and I'm going to set
a keyframe here and we're gonna change
this vertical displacement to something
like 36 and let's expand let's actually
stretch this map to fit there we go go
to the end of our timeline and we're
going to change it to negative
25 and let's preview this and see how it
looks and that's how you create some
displacement mapping parallaxing inside
of After Effects